AUTOMATICKY PREKLAD !! it is necessary to do the whole thing
Very similar to the last but with a slight difference.
And the subtle difference will make a big difference.
Let's say we have a curve integral over some curve c -
I will define the second curve - zx square y
Second Dx and Dy 2xy - And it can look very good
This was very similar to what we saw last time, except the last one
This time we had a closed integral.
This is not a closed integral.
And our curve, c, parameterization is x is
equals cosine t, y equals sine of woods.
Meanwhile - it looks like he's sitting.
Let me write sinus t - so far it looks very similar to
closed integral example we are in last
video but instead t go from 0 to 2 pi, we will
have t go from 0 to pi.
t is greater than or equal to 0, less than or equal to pi.
So now we are basically our way - if I should draw on
XY Plane - That's my y axis, that's my x-axis.
So our path is not around a unit circle.
Our way - our c curve now - just starts t is equal to 0.
It can be imagined that t is almost an angle.
t is equal to 0, and we want to go pi.
So this is our journey right now, in this example.
So it's not a curved road.
This is not a closed path.
So we can't just show that f, in this example - and we are
to re-look at what f looks like - Hey that's it
conservative vector field if it is a closed loop that is equal
0, this is not a closed loop.
So we can't use it.
But let's see if we can use any of our other tools.
As we saw in the last video, it may look like
a little stranger to you.
But when you say f is equal to i, plus
times j then it might look a little more familiar.
When we say that f xy - f vector field equals x
reliability plus y second times i plus 2xy ja Dr. - I am
I don't even have to look at this right now. Dr, you can always
to write it as dx i plus dy x j.
You will instantly see when you have the scalar product of these 2
things when Dr. dot f - are both vector rated
vector award winning differential, valued vector box or vector
Valuable Features - If you dr f dot, you get
Here is.
You get what we have in the interval.
You'll get it, okay?
That times - your product and conditions -
That times it equals it and add it to
product of j conditions.
2xy times dy.
Write it.
So our integral, we can rewrite it like this.
Along this curve f dot dr where is our f.
Now we still want to ask a question, is it
conservative fields?
Or does it have the potential?
Is equal to the transition of some function, the capital ff?
I think I could write the transition because
This creates a vector.
It's like a vector.
Is it true?
And we saw the last video, that's it.
I'll be doing it again a little this time.
Because if that's true, we can't say it's closed
Repeat and say oh that it is equal to 0.
But if that's true, then we know it - that
Integral is a path independent.
nothing here
And we will find that it equals capital F,
If we say that t is z - Well, in this case t is
goes from 0 to pi - we can say it will be
equals capital fi minus capital F 0.
Or if we want to write x and y - because f
there will be x and y - we could write - and that
Right here, these are them
nothing here
We could also write that it equals fx pi, y
pi, minus fx 0, y 0.
It's what I mean when I say f pi.
If we were to write f purely as a function of t.
But we know that this capital f will be a function.
This is a scalar function defined in xy.
So we could say fx pi, y pi.
These are now.
These are all equivalent.
So if it's a path dependent, we can find our f.
We can only evaluate it, just by accepting ours
f, rating on these two points.
At this point and at that moment over there.
Because the way would be independent.
If it is conservative, if it has a potential function,
As for the transition from another Scalar field, and then it
is a conservative vector field and its integral
The road is independent.
It depends only on it and that.
So let's see if we can find our f.
So I'll do exactly what we did in the last video.
If you're watching the last video, it might be
a little monotonous.
But I'll do it a little faster here.
So we know that a partial f for x is being prepared
it must be right here.
So that is the reliability of x plus y to the other.
Which tells us when we take an antiderivative, considering
x, then f xy is going to have to be x to
third over 3 plus xy reliability - right? y on the other is just
constant in terms of x - plus f y.
There may be some y functions when you do
partial for x, just disappears.
And then we know that partial fs with regard to
y has to be equal to it or that.
We say it's a transition f.
So it is supposed to be partial for y.
2xy.
And maybe you would watch the video.
I'll just go a little slower in this one.
So out of that primitive for y - so we get f
xy - would be the same xy reliability plus some
Function x.
Now we're in the last video.
These 2 things must be the same to
transition from capital f to lowercase letters f.
And we have xy reliability, xy squared.
We have a function x, we have a function of pure x.
And then here, we don't have a pure y function
So it has to be 0 here.
We solved.
Our city f xy must be equal to x 3
over 3 plus xy to the other.
We know that lowercase letters f are definitely conservative.
It is a path independent.
It has its potential.
It's a transition over here.
And solve our integral - that was 0 - solve ours
integral, we'll have to figure out x pi, y
pi, x 0, y 0.
Evaluates bullets and then subtracts 2.
So let's go.
Doctor x was the cosine of t, y is the sine of t.
Let me rewrite them down here.
X is therefore equal to cosine t.
y is equal to sine t.
Thus, X 0 is equal to cosine 0, which is equal to 1.
x pi equals cosine pi equal to minus 1.
y 0 is sine 0, which is 0.
y pi, which equals the sine of p, which is equal to 0.
So fx pi, y pi - that's the same,
So I rewrite it.
Our integral is simplified to - our integral along this path
f point dr - will be equal to capital fx pi.
x pi is minus 1.
y is equal to 0.
Minus capital fx 0 is 1, comma y 0 0.
So what is it?
Just remember, here's the same thing
It's right there.
That's x pi.
This is y pi.
Term here.
You can imagine this whole f minus 1, 0 - that's the same